So let's at the solution to our mesh versus
bus throughput quiz where we had four cores with a
totally random and even distribution of traffic among the cores.
We are given what each core is sending, we are
getting what the bus can do and what the link in a mesh can do, and now we are
asked how much faster is it on the bus versus
on the mesh. Our bus cannot sustain the 40 million
messages per second, that the cores are trying
to give it. So the cores are really
going to slow down to half of their speed,
so that the bus bandwidth demand matches what
it can provide. So on the bus, we get 2x the execution time that each core
is capable of providing. On the mesh, we
can support 20 million messages per second per link.
So now the question is, do our links get
saturated? So let's see what we get on a
mesh like this in terms of traffic. Each core
is generating 10 million messages, 3.3 million are going
to each other core. So of the 10 million
messages sent here, one third are going to this
core, one third are going through this link, and
then one third are going here. Let's say that one
sixth go this way, one sixth go this way. So
this link will be used for one sixth of the messages
sent by this core. And this one for another one sixth.
And then we add one sixth to each of these, which
brings us to one half of 10 million messages. So now
we are done with this core. What happens from this core?
Same thing. This link gets one half of the messages. One
third are going here. One sixth are going here. So this
link suffers one half of this traffic again. Now
this link gets one half of the traffic from
this core and these two links get one sixth
each. And now we're done with this core. Now what
happens when this core is sending, one half of
the message go this way, one half go this way.
One sixth of them go through this link, and
one sixth go through this link, done with this core.
And finally, this core sends messages, half here, half here, and then one sixtth
here and one sixth here. Now we are done with this core. So as you can see, our
links are actually evenly used. Each of them
gets two times one half plus two sixths.
So we get one and one third times the traffic generated by one core. That was
what the one half was off. The traffic from one core is 10 million messages a
second. So we're really getting 10 plus 3.3.
So this is 13.3 million of messages per second.
Which is available on, on our mesh. So
the mesh doesn't slow down the processors. So really
the speed up of using the mesh versus
the bus is two because the bus requires the
cores to slow down so that it can
support the traffic that they are generating. While the
mesh allows the cores to proceed at full speed
at 10 million max messages per second. And still
have some traffic left over. If we went to
a larger net and then four cores the bus
will have to proportionately slow down while the mesh
would get more links, and it will be a
while until any of the mesh links become
saturated. So clearly, the mesh is far superior
to the bus in terms of the traffic it can support when we go to more cores.